this Twisted piece of metal is All That
Remains of goodrat's Heritage Bridge the
railings that lined it now form a ladder
for those trying to get out
most of the 233 meter narrow Footbridge
is now submerged in the river below
after it collapsed taking dozens of
people with it including children
my daughter has been admitted to
hospital we heard that the bridge had
collapsed as soon as I heard that the
ambulance had arrived I came to the gate
leaving my other daughters she was
immediately put on a stretcher and taken
inside
foreign
buoyancy AIDS are thrown to people in
the murky Machu River some use them to
paddle back into the center to search
for survivors
all as more ambulances arrive to line
the riverbank
[Music]
the bridge had only reopened a few days
ago after being shut for six months for
renovation work
now bystanders look on in horror at The
Frayed remnants
hundreds used this route every day
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is a major search rescue operation
for them that will continue in the
coming days
the injured continue to arrive at the
local hospital inside panicked families
fill waiting rooms searching for loved
ones
as this tragedy caused by the city's
major landmark unfolds Before Their Eyes
Ashley